we saw him sitting in a chair and
AVENGERS so I'm sitting in a chair in
Guardian
we saw him kind of putting on a glove
and it was time and I always said the
next time we show anything about Thanos
it's going to be standing up hey there
everyone we are here at d23 expo 2017
we're about to talk with some of the
cast and creators of Marvel Studios of
vendors in fan Deewar stay tuned we'll
infinity war answer the burning question
that everyone wants to know which one
does Captain America love the most
Bucky or Falcon it answers that in the
first five in the first five minutes it
is that question it's not even a
question
look at this guy's eyes or that shirt
it's not even a question look at it
what was it like to sort jump into this
movie and jump into the much larger
world of the Avengers in the MCU for me
I think one of the crazy things are
seeing you in costume for the first time
your costume is the coolest costume in
person pretty good don't sign in front
of Mackie
yeah just could ever imagine you'll go
off on one Josh Brolin is now as obvious
you guys cast him a while ago knowing
all this was coming up how it seems like
from that Thanos was always set in your
mind of this is what he was going to be
like is that the case I think so I mean
I think it's very clear from the comics
the type of character that Thanos is we
wanted to emulate that and we were when
we were looking for a voice for Thanos
on guardians the galaxy and he was so
excited to join us he was so excited to
join this world and over now it's been a
number of years he's just transforming
into this character and the character is
transforming into him and as what we
showcase today given how sometimes
dysfunctional the guardians can be how
do you think you guys would fit in with
the rest of the cast of The Avengers
still very dysfunctional for me that's
what we bring to it how is the
experience of being in the full-blown of
vendors film and different than your
other times as Rhodey
well there's more roading I mean there's
more storyline and you know it's clearly
where he was left in it civil
or there's a journey that he's going to
take over these next two movies but a
lot of it is still relatively unknown to
us because we haven't having seen the
next script for this movie yet so I'll
be surprised like you guys are gonna
finally get to check it out which
character are you most excited for fans
to see tracks interact with out of the
larger MCU Tony Stark oh I always
thought with this being so you know
taking everything so literally and Tony
Stark being such a sarcastic wiseass
it would make for like really magical
moments and and sure enough
[Music]